c'est un cadeau avant l'heure pour les
enfants malades du centre hospitalier de
versailles
un spectacle musical et plein d'humour
grâce à l'association greer 78 les
jeunes patients ont pu assister au
concert de sophie forte et son
guitariste régis moreau la chanteuse
également marraine de l'association
participent à l'opération depuis sept
ans sa motivation le bonheur de faire
plaisir aux données de l'agencé pendant
la phase 11
voilà c'est toujours comme ça c'est un
échange sais pas j'ai pas que faire pour
faire plaisir aux autres
c'est vrai que quelque part moi aussi ça
me réjouis de pouvoir voilà amusé des
enfants les rendre à un moment en petits
moments ici le faire partir ailleurs en
tout cas l'action rire pour guérir
permet d'apporter des moments d'évasion
aux patients à leurs familles mais
également au personnel soignant
car ces manifestations fédère aussi les
équipes je pense que c'est important
pour les abîmes dossier d'abord tout
simplement parce que dans nos journées
de travail et bien avoir un petit moment
de détente c'est aussi ça fait du bien
et puis c'est aussi une occasion pour se
réunir
et d'être ensemble pour autre chose les
soins les techniques parler des
traitements les enfants une trentaine
d'enfants étaient présents pour marquer
une pause festive dans leur quotidien
après des débuts timides le public s'est
laissé emporter par les mélodies
entraînantes
super gentil pour les gens qui viennent
pas nous distraire
ouais c'est sympa ça fait oublier un peu
tous les problèmes qu'on ait ou non mais
franchement c'était génial
cette représentation était la dernière
des onze manifestations de ce type qui
ont eu lieu dans différents hôpitaux et
cliniques du département pour la fin
d'année